-All right! All right.
All right.
Okay. We're having a good time
you know?
We're having a good time.
I like to tell people we'r
having a good time, you know
I don't like to ask.
A lot of comics come out her
and they go,
"Are we having a good time?"
Not me. I can't risk it.
You know what I mean?
I like to let you know.
I am pumped to be here, though
I travel around a lot.
I don't always
get the best hotels.
I stay at a lot of hotels.
They're not always the best.
I was in one recently,
and nothing worked.
The elevator didn't work.
Finally got up to my room,
and the Wi-Fi didn't work.
So I went back downstairs
and I was like,
"Hey, the Wi-Fi doesn't work."
And he was like,
"Yeah, it's a little shaky
But the network name is
RamadaInn1."
And that's when I realized
why it was shaky,
because we weren't at
a Ramada Inn.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Hey, thank you.
I could see the Ramada Inn
through the window.
He was like, "But it works rea
good down here in the lobby.
Why don't you just use it
here in the lobby?"
And I'm like, "Well, obviously
you don't know
what I need Wi-Fi for."
You know what I mean?
Okay, we're having a good time
And -- let's not forget -- we're
having a good time.
I was at one hotel, and they had
a sign inside the room
that said, "Not responsibl
for stolen items."
So I took some stuff.
And, I mean, I'm like,
"I'm not responsible either.
I don't even work here.
I've been needing a lamp wit
some plugs on it."
I'm tired of plugging my stuff
into a wall at home, you know?
Get a lamp I can plug
some stuff into.
It's tough to find a lamp
with USB ports on it.
You know what I mean?
You find one, you take it.
That's a rule.
I was at a casino hotel on
time, and they had a sign
in there had a list of
everything you could steal
and how much it cost,
all right?
That way,
if you want to steal it,
they'll just charge you
right to your account,
I guess to keep you
from stealing, right?
But they had an ironing boar
on there for like $20.
I was like, "That seems like a
pretty good deal to me."
You know what I mean?
Like, I don't buy a lot of
ironing boards, so I don't know,
but $20 seems cheap, right
Plus, who's bold enough to steal
an ironing board from a hotel?
Like, a towel, I get.
You can put that into your bag
But an ironing board?
That's bold, right?
You're at checkout like, "Nah,
I had this when I came in.
Yeah, it does look a lot
like yours,
but I always carry
an ironing board with me.
Good thing, 'cause there's not
one in that room."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
We're having a good time.
And I don't even know how to
iron, though, you know?
Like, I know how it works.
You know, like, you plug it into
the lamp, and then...
Okay, we're having a good time
I like to read
bad-hotel reviews.
I read one recently.
This guy was like, "This hotel
room was so disgusting.
There was bugs in the bed,
blood in the carpet.
I felt like I was
going to catch a disease.
And that continental breakfast
was a joke."
I was like, "Dude, you stuck
around for breakfast?
You got to get out of
there, man."
You wouldn't do that at a
friends house, you know?
You wouldn't be like,
"Oh, it's too gross to sleep
Let's check out the fridge."
You know what I mean?
Okay. All right.
And I hate staying
at people's houses, though
I like a hotel.
You know, you have to follow
people's rules at their houses
You don't know what to expect.
You ever go to somebody's hous
and they got a dog
that's barking at you,
growling at you?
And they go,
"Ah, he won't bite."
It's like,
"Why do you think that?"
"'Cause he's never
done it before?
Well, maybe today is the day
'Cause he looks like
he wants to bite."
They're always like, "Well, he
might lick you to death."
I'm like, "Death?
Who said anything about dying?
I'm just worried about
being bitten.
I don't even know why you
brought up death."
I just think it's
a weird idea, right?
'Cause the dog looks like
it wants to bite you.
It's like you show up at
somebody's house,
and there's some guy
in there with a knife.
And he's just doing like this.
Huh?
They're like,
"Ah, he won't stab you.
Uh, he might lick you to death
Yeah, he'll settle down
in a minute.
He's just not used to bein
around people."
All right.
We're having a good time.
Thank you, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-That is how you do it
right there.
That is how you do it.
Dusty Slay!
For more, go to dustyslay.com.